HILTON IS COMING UP NEXT.
>> GOOD EVENING.
I'M STEVE HILTON AND THIS IS
THE HOME OF POSITIVE
POPULISM.
WE HAVE AN IMPORTANT SPECIAL
FOR YOU TONIGHT.
TIME AND AGAIN AS WE COVER
POLITICS AND ESPECIALLY THE
RIDE OF SOCIALISM AND
INTOLERANCE YOU SEE ON THE
LEFT, I'M REMINDED OF GEORGE
ORWELL IN THE CLASSIC NOVEL IN
1984 WHEN THE INTRODUCED YOU
TO THE WORLD OF "BIG BROTHER"
IS WATCHING YOU.
IN FACT OUR CULTURE IN MANY
WAYS INCREASINGLY RESEMBLES
THAT WORLD AND THOSE
SIMILARITIES THAT WE WILL
INVESTIGATE TONIGHT.
GREAT GUEST INCLUDING ADAM
COROLLA.
LET'S SET THINGS UP WITH OUR
GUESTS ABOUT JUST HOW MUCH
TODAY'S SOCIETY VERY MIRRORED
1984.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK.
>> IT'S DRAMATIC, IT ACTUALLY
REMINDS ME OF THE OTHER
CRITIQUE IN THIS.
AS I WAS READING IT, IT WAS A
CONSTANT REMINDER AND THAT
TOOK ME TO IT, I JUST WANT TO
SHOW YOU THIS CLICKABLE TALK
ABOUT IN A SECOND PERIOD JUST
HAVE A LOOK
HAVE A  LOK
HAVE A  LOOK.
>> THAT'S THE APPLE
COMMERCIAL.
>> I REMEMBER IT.
>> SO ICONIC.
IT WAS THINK DIFFERENT AND SO
MUCH OF WHAT YOU DESCRIBED,
THIS NEW AUTHORITARIANISM OF
THE LEFT, IT'S THROUGH SOCIAL
MEDIA.
>> IT'S THE IRONY OF IT ALL.
>> BUT IT'S TRUE.
>> IT IS.
LOOK, I WAS SORT OF ON THAT
FRONT PROLONGED TIME.
THERE WAS SOMETHING ABOUT THIS
LANGUAGE POLICING OVER THE
PAST THREE OR FOUR YEARS THAT
BOTHERED ME SO MUCH BECAUSE
I'M AN ARTIST AND I'M A WRITER
, AND MAYBE I'M MORE OFFENDED
THAN THE AVERAGE PERSON ABOUT
HAVING TO WATCH WHAT I SAY OR
FOLLOW A LIST OF RULES OF HER
WANT TO WRITE SOMETHING OR I'M
GOING TO CREATE SOMETHING.
THAT IS THE IRONY OF IT ALL
THAT IT REALLY STEMS FROM THAT
SIDE OF THE AISLE.
I LOOK BACK AND IT ALWAYS HAS,
AMERICAN PSYCHO, THE
CANCELLATION OF MY NOVEL IN
1990 OR 1991 WAS FROM THE LEFT
AS WELL.
IT WAS FROM MAINSTREAM MEDIA
AND IT WAS FROM THE
NATURALIZATION OF WOMEN IN
THOSE KIND OF GROUPS GEORGE
ORWELL WAS PUBLISHED ALMOST
EXACTLY 70 YEARS AGO.
HE WAS RIDING IN THE EARLY
DAYS OF THE SOVIET UNION
BEFORE ITS FULL COURSE BECAME
KNOWN BUT HE COULD SEE WHAT
WAS HEADING.
THE WORLD HE DESCRIBED IN 1984
IS HIS PRODUCTION OF WHERE
SOCIALISM ENDS UP.
WHERE THE RULING ELITE MAKEUP
JUST 2% OF THE POPULATION WITH
A SMALL MIDDLE-CLASS AND THE
MAJORITY OF CITIZENS
UNEDUCATED WORKERS.
THE RULING PARTY CONTROLS THE
POPULATION THROUGH FOR
MINISTRIES.
THE MINISTRY OF PEACE THAT
DEALS WITH WORK AND PLENTY AND
RATIONS FOOD MINISTRY OF LOVE
IS IN CONTROL OF LAW AND ORDER
THE MINISTRY OF TRUTH HAS A
FIRM GRIP ON ENTERTAINMENT AND
EDUCATION.
JUST LISTEN TO WHAT HE WROTE
ABOUT THE ELITE SPREAD IF
LEISURE AND SECURITY WERE
ENJOYED BY ALL THE GREAT MASS
OF HUMAN BEINGS NORMALLY
STUPEFIED BY POVERTY WOULD
BECOME LITERATE LISTS AND
LEARN TO THINK FOR THEMSELVES
AND ONCE THEY HAD DONE THUS
THEY WOULD REALIZE THAT THE
PRIVILEGED MINORITY HAVE NO
FUNCTION AND THEY WOULD SWEEP
IT AWAY.
IN THE LONG RUN A HIERARCHICAL
SOCIETY IS ONLY POSSIBLE ON A
BASIS OF POVERTY AND
IGNORANCE.
IT'S A VISION THAT SEEMS TO
BECOMING MORE TRUE EACH DAY
FROM GOVERNMENT SURVEILLANCE
AND SOCIAL MEDIA MOBS
INFLUENCING PUBLIC THOUGHT AND
THE PUSH TO REWRITE HISTORY.
OUR WORLD IS STARTING TO
RESEMBLE THE FRIGHTENING VIEW
OF THE FUTURE AND THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT SHOULD SCARE
EACH AND EVERY ONE OF US.
WE WILL TAKE A LOOK AT SOME
SPECIFIC EXAMPLES THROUGHOUT
THE SHOW, BUT FIRST I WANT TO
BRING IN OUR GUEST.
COMEDIAN AND HOST ADAM COROLLA
AND RED STATE EDITOR AT LARGE
KEIRA DAVIS.
THERE'S SO MUCH TO UNPACK
HERE.
I JUST WANT TO START WITH THE
BIG THEME OF THE WHOLE THING
WHICH IS HIGHLY RELEVANT
ESPECIALLY WHEN YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THE WAY THE DEMOCRATIC
PARTY IS MOVING.
THE WAY IN WHICH SOCIALISM HAS
SO QUICKLY BECOME NORMALIZED
WITHIN THE DEMOCRATIC DEBATE.
DO YOU THINK THERE'S A SENSE
IN WHICH IT INEVITABLY ENDS UP
MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION OF
THE TOTALITARIAN AUTHORITARIAN
STATE THAT CONTROLS PEOPLE?
WHEREVER IT STARTS, THAT'S
WHERE IT ENDS UP.
>> IF YOU CAN ABOUT THE PHRASE
OR THE TERM PROGRESSIVE
MOVEMENT, IT SAYS MOVING
PROGRESSIVELY.
IT'S NEVER STOP AND TAKE
INVENTORY OF WHERE WERE GOING
OR HOW FAST WERE GOING.
IT'S JUST MOVE FORWARD AND I
ALWAYS SORT OF THINK OF IT
LIKE, WHEN I WAS A KID YOU
COULD SMOKE CIGARETTES IN AN
AIRPLANE, YOU COULD SMOKE
CIGARETTES ANYWHERE, BUT JUST
TAKE A LOOK AT CIGARETTES AS A
METAPHOR PRESENT AT SOME .70
SAID LOOK, WE CAN HAVE YOU
SMOKING IN THE RESTAURANT,
AROUND THE KIDS, WITH OTHER
PEOPLE, WERE EATING, WHEN WE
HAVE A SMOKING SECTION AND
PEOPLE WENT OKAY AND THEY
PICKED UP THEIR PLATE AND
THEIR ASHTRAY AND THEY WENT
SMOKING SECTION, OVER THERE.
THEY MOVED THOSE SMOKING
SECTIONS.
TEN MINUTES LATER THEY CAME
AND THEY SAID WE DON'T WANT
SMOKING IN THE RESTAURANT, BUT
IF YOU'D LIKE TO GO TO THE BAR
AND SMOKE YOU CAN GO TO THE
BAR AND SMOKE WHEN THEY SAID
OKAY, HAVE A DRINK AT A BAR
AND SMOKE.
THEN THEY CAME TO THOSE PEOPLE
AND SAID WE DON'T WANT
ANYTHING IN THE RESTAURANT,
BUT IF YOU JUST WANT TO STEP
OUT ONTO THE SIDEWALK AND HAVE
A CIGARETTE, HAVE A CIGARETTE
AND THEY WENT IT'S COLD, BUT
OKAY AND THEY WALKED OUT.
AND THEN THEY SAID YOU'RE TOO
CLOSE TO THE FRONT DOOR, WE
NEED YOU TO MOVE IT DOWN THE
STREET TO THE PARK AND THEY
SAID OKAY AND THEY WENT TO THE
PARK AND THEN SOMEBODY SAID WE
DON'T WANT SMOKING AT THE PARK
AND IT'S A PROGRESSIVE
MOVEMENT.
THE THOUGHT IS, LET'S GET THE
CIGARETTE SMOKE OUT OF THE
RESTAURANT.
NO, NO, THAT'S NOT THE END OF
THE MOVEMENT.
IT'S A MOVEMENT THAT NEVER
STOPS.
WERE GOING TO KEEP GOING AFTER
YOU UNTIL YOU CAN'T SMOKE IN
YOUR APARTMENT BECAUSE THE KID
ABOVE YOU IS GONNA GET
SECONDHAND SMOKE.
THEY DON'T STOP ENOUGH.
I REALIZED, I REALIZED THE NRA
CAUGHT ONTO THIS AND THERE
SITTING IN THE RESTAURANT AND
THEY SAY WE LIKE THAT LAW,
BANANA CLIPS ON AK-47S AND
THEY SAY NOPE, WERE NOT
GETTING UP AND MOVING BECAUSE
WE KNOW IF WE GET UP AND MOVE,
EVENTUALLY WERE GOING TO BE
OUT THE SIDEWALK AND IT'S
SNOWING OUTSIDE.
>> REALLY PARROTED SO GREAT.
EVERYONE WILL RELATE TO THAT
AND IT JUST CAPTURES IT,
DOESN'T IT, BECAUSE IN THE END
YOU CAN SAY GOOD INTENTIONS,
HEALTHCARE AND NO ONE TO BE
POOR, BUT THE END RESULT IS
THIS PROGRESSION TOWARD MORE
AND MORE CONTROL OVER PEOPLE.
>> I WANT TO READ THIS QUOTE,
IT WAS MY FAVORITE QUOTE FROM
THE BIOGRAPHY OF GEORGE
WASHINGTON WRITTEN BY CHIEF
JUSTICE JOHN MARSHALL, A MAN
WHO KNEW HIM.
HE WAS WRITING THIS ABOUT THE
FOUNDING OF AMERICA, THE EARLY
DAYS OF THE
DAYS OF AHE
DAYS OF AMERICA.
SO TRUE THAT MEN CLOSER EYE ON
ENCROACHMENT BY THAT PARTY TO
WHICH THEY ARE ATTACHED AND
HOPE THAT POWER IN SUCH HANDS
WILL ALWAYS BE WIELDED AGAINST
THEIR ADVERSARIES AND NEVER
AGAINST THEMSELVES.
THAT'S WHERE WE ARE WITH THE
FREE SPEECH.
IT'S LIKE OH IT'S FINE, WERE
JUST OUTLAWING THOSE DIRTY,
BIGOTED HOMOPHOBIC
REPUBLICANS, WERE DOING THE
RIGHT THING, THAT'S FINE,
THESE WILL NEVER COME AROUND
TO BITE US IN THE BUTT MORE AT
THIS PLACE NOW WHERE IT RAINS
ON THE RIGHTEOUS.
THE LAWS RAINED DOWN ON ALL OF
US AND I THINK WERE FINALLY
REACHING CRITICAL MASS WHERE
PEOPLE ARE LIKE HOLD ON, THIS
ISN'T WHAT I MEANT, I DIDN'T
MEAN FOR US TO GET WRAPPED UP
IN THIS, I MEANT THAT FOR YOU
GUYS.
>> I KNOW THAT MANY ON THE
LEFT REALLY OBJECT TO THE
COMPARISONS WHERE IT IF IT
SOCIALISM IN VENEZUELA OR
WHATEVER, I KNOW WHAT I'M
TALKING ABOUT BECAUSE MY
FAMILY IS FROM HUNGARY.
THEY GREW UP UNDER COMMUNISM,
THE MOTHER AND FATHER LEFT
WENT FOR FREEDOM IN THE UK.
THEY LEFT THE FAMILY BACK IN
HUNGARY.
OF COURSE IT'S NOT LITERALLY
TRUE THAT COMMUNISM IN THE WAY
THAT BERNIE SANDERS PLATFORM
IS, BUT THE POINT HERE AND THE
POINT THAT ADAM PUT SO WELL IS
THAT IT DOESN'T ALWAYS END UP
MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION
BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE TRYING TO
DO THINGS FOR EVERYONE, IN THE
END THAT BRINGS WITH IT THE
NECESSITY OF GOVERNMENT
COERCION AND CONTROL.
>> I LOVE THAT ANALOGY THAT
ADAM DID AND I'M IN A
PIGGYBACK BY SAYING WHO
DETERMINES WHAT'S THE CANCER.
WHO DETERMINES WHAT'S GOOD AND
WHAT'S BAD.
WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT OKAY LET'S
MOVE THE SMOKERS OUT GO LITTLE
BIT FURTHER, THE REASON WAS
WERE SAYING IT'S A HEALTH
HAZARD.
WE ARE LITERALLY HAVING PEOPLE
DETERMINE WHAT IS GOOD AND BAD
FOR PEOPLE WHEN IT COMES TO
FREE SPEECH.
WHAT IS THE CANCER THAT GETS
AMONG US AND TAKES CONTROL.
WHEN I SIGNED UP WITH BERNIE
SANDERS IT WAS FOR THIS REASON
THAT YOU CAN'T JUST CHOOSE ONE
PERSON AND HAVE NO OTHER
INDEPENDENT THOUGHTS.
WHAT THAT HAS HAPPENED WITH
THE SANDERS MOVEMENT IS NOW
THE SAME PEOPLE THAT WERE
SAYING LISTEN WE WANT
DIFFERENT OPINIONS, NOW HIS
FOLLOWERS ARE SAYING NO, IT'S
EITHER HIS WAY OR THE HIGHWAY,
WE DON'T WANT INDEPENDENT
THOUGHTS, WE DON'T WANT TO
HEAR ANYBODY ELSE'S VIEWS SO
JUST PLAYS BACK TO ANALOGIES
AND IT'S NEVER ENOUGH.
WE GO FURTHER AND FURTHER AND
FURTHER.
NO MATTER WHAT WE DO OR SAY
IT'S NEVER AMOUNT
IT'S NEVER EMOUNT
IT'S NEVER ENOUNT
IT'S NEVER ENOUGT
IT'S NEVER ENOUGH.
THIS IS ABSENTLY GOING TO HURT
AFRICAN-AMERICANS.
I TALKED ABOUT IT TIME AND
TIME AGAIN.
I BELIEVE INJUSTICE AND
JUSTICE MEANS WE TAKE INTO
ACCOUNT BOTH SIDES OF THE
TESTIMONY THAT WE ACTUALLY
LOOK AT THINGS FROM AN
OBJECTIVE STANDPOINT.
THIS HANG THEM HI, SPREAD THEM
WIDE IDEOLOGY BASED OFF OF ONE
THING THAT SOMEONE SAID LIKE
THE "ME TOO" MOVEMENT, OF
COURSE I BELIEVE WOMEN, BUT WE
CAN'T JUST BE IN A SOCIETY
THAT SAY WE BELIEVE WOMEN NO
MATTER WHAT WE WANT TAKE
ANYBODY'S ACCOUNT.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY GOING TO
COME BACK AND BITE US.
>> WERE GOING TO GET TO THAT
LATER IN THIS SHOW IN THE
WHOLE QUESTION OF LANGUAGE IS
REALLY AT THE HEART OF IT.
BEFORE WE TAKE A BREAK, BE
SURE TO CHECK OUT MY LATEST
EPISODE OF DEEP DIVE ON FOX
NATION.COM WHERE WE TALK ABOUT
HEALTHCARE.
>> CORRECT ME IF I'M WRONG BUT
MEDICAID IS A FORM OF PUBLIC
OPTION AND IT DOESN'T WORK.
>> DON'T SAY IT WORKS IN
CALIFORNIA.
>> IT'S CALLED MEDI-CAL AND A
THIRD OF CALIFORNIANS ARE NOW
ON MEDI-CAL.
THE PROBLEM IS THERE PAID 40%
BELOW WHAT THEY GET PAID FOR